i was born in tel aviv israel we used to
go back there every summer between 1967
and 1970 and literally spend all day on
the beach as three brothers and so being
a being there did shape us actually
considerably and they were very
important years between the age of 10
and 13 so I would say that it would it
turned out to be a very important
shaping experience and a large part of
that shaping was simply being in a
country that was a terrorist attacks was
struggling but was very vibrant but also
having no agenda and just spending two
months at a stretch on the beach playing
around playing with your brothers and
talking with your brothers and doing all
sorts of stuff
as a young person I'd say that problem a
very dominant influence on my life was
my maternal grandfather Herman small a
he was came here in the early 20th
century escaped from Russia actually
smuggled in illegal immigrant he worked
in the meatpacking industry in in and
around Chicago he was a union organizer
very early on built the synagogue a very
big man very heavy very big hands of a
manual labor very committed to trying to
make everyone's life better we used to
spend a lot of days riding in the back
of his station wagon as he delivered he
eventually got into specialty foods to
us food imports from Switzerland and
Sweden and Denmark and used to deliver
them to specialty food stores way before
the sort of gourmet food crisis was in
the 60s no one had heard of gourmet
cheeses he was doing that and we used to
sit in the back of his car for hours
just driving all over Illinois all over
Wisconsin all over Indiana and talking
to him and he's a very very caring
person and then for a couple of years he
moved into our house he sold everything
and then at the age of I think 72 is
going to immigrate to Israel but it
turned out he was an illegal immigrant
in the United States so he had no
passport to leave the country and so he
had sold everything so he moved into our
house and he used to wake up at you know
four o'clock in the morning and when you
got up he would make you this breakfast
that was unbelievable of double yoke
decks he could get double yolk bags from
the specialty farms and you know all
sorts of fresh squeezed oranges all this
stuff and what he did for other people
in the fact that it was very important
for him to care for other people and
make sure that everyone else was being
cared for was very it's a very very
important thing second important thing
was my mother was heavily involved in
the civil rights movement in the early
1960s way before and we were a family
that had a lot of black friends we spent
a lot of time on the west side of
Chicago with African American people and
probably one of the most formative
experiences there
21 my mom I wouldn't say every day but
not infrequently got arrested and would
not end up being back home at night and
so that was a very interesting
experience and the other was that we
marched when when martin luther king
came to chicago had marched to cicero we
were on that marches kids and we were
pelted with rotten tomatoes and eggs and
very serious perience you never forget
that kind of stuff and we were able to
hear Martin Luther King as well in
person and those are I would say among
the many formative experiences or at
least people who were formative to me
I love this question because everyone
asks things like what did your mother
feed you you know what was it about the
family and no one even though that we're
in the age of molecular biology says God
there must be something in the genetics
of that family so which i always find
interesting big a doctor and a sort of
scientists myself why people think its
environment and not naturally genetics
it's a really good question I think that
there are lots and lots of things I
think we did have very committed
socially committed parents socially
committed grandfather that was one
element very important we had a very
verbal family you know if you didn't
talk and you didn't get in there with
your opinion you know you were nobody we
had a very competitive but loving in
this I think is one of the very
complicated things to arrange in the
family anyone who's been a parent
understands so my brothers and I were
very competitive but we were also loving
for example as i mentioned in Israel we
spend all summers together and it was
really us three and so we had to get a
log we had to struggle with each other
we had to approve each other and so I
think that also creates a bond I think
one of the interesting things that
defines all of us is people who work
with us and for us are very loyal and
feel like we're very very committed to
them into their success and so I think
that's something that we have this sort
of very interested in promoting people
very interested in and having people
work hard but also recognizing their
contribution is very important and i
would i would think that in our family
public affairs was very important my
father was born in israel american
sports meant zilch to him absolutely
nothing he never took us to a baseball
game basketball game we never i would
say wasted our time in a lot of energy
that was directed out that you know and
i would say the other thing is success
is unpredictable in the following sense
i was a very successful student in
school the eldest and all that crap that
goes along with being the eldest
but my other two brothers were not so
successful in school and it's not
because they ain't smart but they were
in my shadow and they needed you know
their own platform and their own stage
and it really wasn't until I left
college that that became possible